قليل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو عاد ليؤكد بان اسرائيل ستستمر في
سياسه الدفاع عن النفس انت كمحامي كيف
تفهم ذلك هل اسرائيل لن تلتزم بما صدر
اليوم من المحكمه محكمه العدده الدوليه
برايك لسوء الحظ نحن نشاهد
دوله تهمش نفسها بنفسها وتضع نفسها على
هامش المجتمع عندما يصدر قرار عن قاض
يتعين على الول ان تحترم هذه
القرارات السيد
نتنياهو قيل له بشكل مباشر انه يتعين عليه
ان يتوقف عن قتل الاطفال الفلسطينيين هو
لديه اطفال وبالتالي يجب ان يفهم اللغه
الانسانيه وايضا اللغه القانونيه وهو يدخل
اسرائيل في مازق ما سوف نراه الان هو رد
الفعل من قبل الحلفاء الاساسيين المانيا
على سبيل المثال قالت انها سوف تحترم قرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه وبالتالي يتعين على
المانيا ان تتوقف عن امداد اسرائيل
بالاسلحه بالاضافه الى فرنسا على سبيل
المثال وبالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك عد من المحامين يهتمون
بالموقف الامريكي وبالتالي القرار لم يوقف
ابدا اي مجرم بشكل مباشر طبعا هذه ليست
ضابطه عدليه ولكن المحكمه تجبر تجبر او
تلزم دوله اسرائيل وبالتالي السيد نتنياهو
ببعض التدابير والا هو على هامش المجتمع
الدولي الحكومه الاسرائيليه لم تعد حكومه
ديمقراطيه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تنتهك القوانين بشكل
كامل وشامل وهو بالتالي يضع نفسه على هامش
المجتمع الدولي وبالتالي المجتمع
الاسرائيلي كذلك ما من مستقبل لهم في
العالم في حال لم يحترموا القانون الدولي
وارى اليوم في الحقيقه ان المقاومه
المسلحه بالفعل يجب ان ترى بشكل بعين
ايجابيه هذا القرار لانه وصف الماي
بالارهاب ولكن في حقيقه الامر هي مجموعه
مقاومه تدافع عن شعب وبالتالي هذه نقطه
اساسيه بالنسبه الى دوله اسرائيل طبعا
السيد نتنياهو يمكنه ان يدلي باي تصريح
يريد ولكن اليد القويه ليست له بل للقانون
الدولي كان لافتا سيد جيل ان التصويت
اليوم كان شبه اجماع وربما هذا يطرح
السؤال الى اي مدى ض في ذلك ويضيف قوه
لهذا القرار وبالتالي يحرج الدول الداعمه
لاسرائيل على راسها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بكل تاكيد كما سبق واسفت بالقول
نحن نتحدث عن قرار شامل اي ايقاف كل
التصرفات التي تنتهك الماده الثانيه
وبالتالي ذلك وارد في اتفاقيه منع جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه وبالتالي يتوقف قتل
المدنيين هذه نقطه اساسيه وايضا بالنسبه
الى قرار المحكمه المحكمه اتخذت او اتخذ
القرار فيها
باكثر ساحقه طبعا
هناك الكثير من الانتقادات التي وجهت الى
القاضيه التي هي ادارت وطبعا الانتقادات
وجهت بانها امريكيه وبالتالي لن تتخذ
القرارات الى اخره ولكنها اثبتت العكس ما
من هامش للتحرك لنتنياهو حتى ولو استمر
بالصراخ هو والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين
الاخرين ليس لديهم هامش للتحرك انتم
ترتكبون افعال تعرف على انها اباده جماعيه
ويتعين على الدول الغربيه ايضا ان تاخذ
ذلك بعين الاعتبار وبالنسبه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه من ناحيه اخرى نقاش سوف
يكون مبسطا بشكل اكبر لان محكمه العدل
الدوليه بتت اليوم بالجانب والحيز
القانوني الامر انتهى الان نتحدث عن
قرارات يمكن ان تصدر عن المحكمه وهناك
اكثريه عظمى اتخذت هذا القرار على مستوى
محكمه العدل الدوليه وهذا يؤثر على الدول
الاوروبيه فرنسا المانيا هولندا الدول
الاوروبيه المختلفه اسرائيل تخاطر بخساره
دعم حلفائها وهذا